[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec le député européen du
rassemblement national à nicolas bay
bonjour un écho l'abbé merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation bonjour je
voudrais vous faire réagir pour
commencer sur la dénonciation d'une
censure de facebook
ces jardins barre de la et marion
maréchal-le pen qui dénonce cette
censure qui pour eux facebook menaçant
fait d'eux des publier des pages de
soutien au mouvement génération
identitaire oui c'est très inquiétant
parce qu'en réalité c'est pas seulement
qu'il menace de dépublier débat c'est
qu'ils le font ils suspendent des
comptes ils le font sur des critères
arbitraires qui ne correspondent en
aucune manière aux critères de la loi
telle qu'elle doit s'appliquer en france
donc c'est très grave parce qu'il ya
finalement une dérive des dégâts femmes
des géants du numérique visant
finalement à privatiser un certain
nombre de libertés publiques c'est pas
simplement sur les sujets qui concernent
génération identitaire c'est beaucoup
plus vaste que ça puisque il ya quelques
semaines seulement il avait quand même
purement et simplement suspendus ils
n'ont toujours pas établi d'ailleurs le
compte du président des états unis et
qu'il faut en finir avec cette dérive
dégâts femmes il faut rappeler la
primauté du droit français sur le
territoire national et ça doit
s'appliquer aussi au domaine du
numérique moi j'ai eu l'occasion il ya
quelques il ya deux ans au parlement
européen d' interpeller
mark zuckerberg le pdg de facebook sur
cette question il avait d'ailleurs
répondu de manière très alambiquée mais
je crois que ça nécessite maintenant que
les pouvoirs publics se saisissent du
sujet qu'ils défendent la liberté
d'expression et s'ils ne le font pas et
bien ils seront complices justement les
pouvoirs publics vis-à-vis des gaffes à
aujourd'hui
la posture de ses pouvoirs publics
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus parce qu'on a le sentiment
quand même qu' il y a une peur des états
vis-à-vis de ses gaffes ah oui c'est
vrai c'est une dérive inquiétante
c'était on voit bien que les pouvoirs
publics en france et dans d'autres pays
sont un peu tétanisé face aux géants du
numérique il ya il faut leur rappeler
que la législation s'applique à tout le
monde y compris à eux qu'ils ne peuvent
pas atteindre à la liberté d'expression
qui doivent respecter la diversité la
pluralité des opinions et la loi elle
doit s'appliquer dans tous les domaines
complémentaires fiscal il faut que là où
ils fassent leur chiffre d'affaires ils
payent leurs impôts dans le
le temps il ya aussi du côté de réseaux
sociaux une volonté justement de gérer
les les publications de manière à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de propos haineux ça
c'est vraiment le débat du moment
génération identitaire est menacée de
dissolution au motif notamment que c'est
une association qui incitent à la
discrimination et au racisme
qu'est ce qu'ils disent ils disent
simplement que les français réalité en
france brit air en france c'est la
définition même d'ailleurs de la
citoyenneté qui donne des droits
supplémentaires à celui qui a la
citoyenneté d'un pays par rapport à
celui qu'il n'a pas donc finalement ces
jeunes il m il met surtout en lumière la
faiblesse du gouvernement français
l'incapacité du gouvernement français à
défendre et à protéger nos frontières
vous légitimez leur leur mode d'action
on sait qu'ils ont mené des opérations
anti migrants par exemple et gérald
darmanin reproche à génération
identitaire de ce site situé d'une
certaine manière à l'état à l'autorité
de l'état
non mais je crois que ce sont des
accusations qui sont pas fondées puisque
génération identitaire a fait l'objet de
deux procès ils ont été relaxés dans les
deux cas donc ces accusations de deux
prétendues violences etc semblent pas du
tout fondées moi je ne partage pas
nécessairement le mode d'action de
génération identitaire mais je constate
que c'est des jeunes qui ont le droit de
dire ce qu'ils disent
dans le cas de la liberté d'expression
et je crois que c'est l'honneur des
françaises et des français qui sont
lucides sur cette question de le dire et
de dénoncer cette situation
une dissolution que génération
identitaire quelles seraient les
conséquences selon vous écoutez ce
serait un précédent extrêmement grave
que des associations islamistes soit
dissous c'est normal puisqu'il porte une
idéologie qui portent atteinte à la
halle à la république française et à nos
valeurs fondamentales mais en revanche
s'agissant de génération identitaire ou
de toute autre association d'ailleurs
qui défend des positions politiques dans
le cadre d'un débat public est légitime
et bien c'est absolument scandaleux et
ce serait extrêmement grave extrêmement
lourd de conséquences de l'issue d'une
telle association
une autre polémique qui concerne l'
influence de l'islamo gauchisme
à l'université 1 c'est le ministre la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal qui soit diligenté une
enquête vous êtes pour
bah oui je crois qu'il faut non
seulement diligenter une enquête
il faut déjà faire preuve de lucidité
sur la question madame vital madame
vidal semble faire preuve de lucidité
mais il faut surtout éradiquer
l'islamisme dans nos universités
les universités sont les des lieux de de
transmission du savoir ou doit veiller
l'esprit français de d'ouverture et de
et de liberté d'expression et d'opinion
et donc voir l'islamisme dans grainé nos
universités c'est là aussi une dérive
très inquiétant donc l'islamisme vagues
et non mais faut quand même distingué
l'islamisme 1 c'est vrai de ce concept
du slam au gauchisme et pas faire
l'amalgamme bas l'islamo gauchisme c'est
la jonction entre entre l'extrême gauche
et l'islamisme c'est pas une idéologie
qui est plus respectable que l'islamisme
c'est simplement la traduction dans le
débat public d'une sorte de
bienveillance de de tendresse presse
pour être au delà de l'extrême gauche à
l'égard de l'islamisme
quand monsieur mélenchon et ses amis
étaient allés défilé il ya quelques mois
avec le ccf qui a été dissous depuis on
entendait crier 'allah akbar' dans la
foule et on voyait tout l'extrême gauche
rassembler derrière les islamistes
juste sur cette enquête qui concerne
donc les universités laisse que vous ne
voyez pas quand même une atteinte aux
libertés fondamentales sur ce point donc
je crois qu'une enquête c'est légitime
que l'islamisme n'est pas sa place dans
les universités françaises ça doit être
rappelé avec force
est ce que nous nous défendons c'est une
loi non pas une loi telle que celle qui
a été adoptée il ya quelques jours qui
finalement est très floue avec quelques
avancées minaire dans quelques domaines
mais ne règle pas fondamentalement le
problème de l'islamisme en france il
faut une loi qui tient qui indique
clairement que l'islamisme et du nez
d'un logis fondamentalement incompatible
avec la france avec nos valeurs avec les
lois de la république et qu'à ce titre
elle doit être combattue par tous dans
les universités comme ailleurs le fait
une enclave est née elle est bien le
minimum profus ce faire il
beaucoup d'universitaires notamment des
études scientifiques y affirme que
justement ce terme un d'islamo gauchisme
et puis c'est un terme qui est
instrumentalisée par l'extrême droite je
ne crois pas parce qu'il est largement
utilisé par par des gens de courants
philosophiques ou politiques très divers
je crois qu'il définit encore une fois
l'islamo gauchisme ça définit assez
clairement cette jonction assez
inquiétante entre une partie de la
gauche politique ou de l'extrême gauche
et cette idéologie islamiste et donc ça
doit être combattue ça doit être d'abord
traitée comme telle définit comment
dénoncer comme tel est ensuite traitée
alors pour beaucoup c'est quand même un
débat stérile dans le contexte actuel
puisse quand on traverse à une pandémie
un an après injustement le début de
cette crise sanitaire
quel bilan vous faites de la gestion du
gouvernement au niveau national mais
aussi européen
je crois qu'il ya eu une défaillance des
poids public en france et aussi à
l'échelle européenne c'est vrai dans un
manque de préparation et d'anticipation
de cette crise sanitaire
lorsqu'il ya un peu plus d'un an
maintenant décembre 2010 9 en janvier
2020 nous avions des indicateurs qui est
inquiétant ils n'ont pas été pris au
sérieux
il n'y a pas eu de la part des menus de
m'apprendre son gouvernement de
commandes il ya deux mesures
d'anticipation sur les masques sur les
tests nous avons pris un retard
considérable
nous n'avons jamais rattrapé dans ces
domaines et puis ensuite il ya une
succession de mesures qui portent
gravement atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales certaines étaient
peut-être nécessaire mais elle était
souvent prise de manière assez
incohérente de manière assez injuste on
entasse les français dans le métro non
leur intérêt dit d'aller sur les
remontées mécaniques aux sports d'hiver
on laisse les enfants dans les écoles ou
dans les eaux où les français dans les
supermarchés mais on interdit les accès
aux salles de théâtre ou de cinéma
alors pourquoi y respecter les
protocoles sanitaires un certain nombre
de mesures incohérentes et puis la
dernière en date c'est évidemment la la
la la faillite de véritable faillite des
poids publique française sur la question
du vaccin
on voit que sur le vaccin on a fait un
tort considérable on s'est enfermés dans
le carcan de l'union européenne la
commission européenne
a fait une commande groupée de vaccins
tous les pays qui n'ont optique qui ont
pris d'autres dispositions de leur côté
s'en sortent aujourd'hui beaucoup mieux
et il ya deux chiffres qui sont très
parlants un pays voisin un grand pays
voisin avec une population équivalente à
celle de la france
je parle du royaume uni aujourd'hui à
plus de 15 millions de personnes qui ont
été vaccinées alors qu'en france on est
à peine à trois millions de français qui
ont une
la première dose unique nicolas bay on
va marquer une courte pause et on va
poursuivre dans un instant restez avec
nous sur rt france retour dans la grande
interview nous sommes avec le député
européen du rassemblement national à
nicolas bay on évoquait justement la
gestion de la pandémie
nicolas bay et vous évoquer le cas du
royaume uni où c'est vrai le royaume uni
a confiné à mener campagne de
vaccination assez massive contrairement
à ce qui se passe dans de nombreux pays
européens dont le nôtre mais il ya la
question aussi des libertés on voit bien
que par exemple sur la question du
confinement
la stratégie qui est menée aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement c'est de dire bien
on va préserver une certaine liberté
quand même pour les français aujourd'hui
pour le gouvernement
on arrive enfin à prendre des mesures
territorialisées c'est ce que nous
défendions depuis des mois dire que
c'était absurde d'imposer de manière
très contraignante très administratif
finalement des aides formelle à
l'ensemble de la france alors que les
disparités considérables dans la
situation épidémique selon les régions
de france
donc ce qui a été fait par le
gouvernement confinement général
couvre-feu général attestation
systématique c'est non seulement une
manière d'infantiliser les français ce
que quasiment aucun pays européen n'a
fait mais de surcroît ce n'était pas
forcément efficace parce que les
situations étaient très diverses
aujourd'hui on fait du confinement
territorialisée à nice sans doute à
dunkerque également mais il faut le
faire dans les deux sens c'est que s'il
ya des mesures de restriction des
libertés qui sont prises pour endiguer
l'épidémie
là où elle est là où elle prospère et
bien à l'inversé beaucoup de régions la
mienne la normandie par exemple est
faiblement touchés par le virus
us et bien les régions qui sont moins
touchés bien il faut desserrer l'étau il
faut ré ouvrir les les lieux cultuels
réouvrir peut-être les restaurants et
les bas évidemment avec des protocoles
sanitaires strip qu'il s'agit pas de
commettre des imprudences
mais il faut que ce cette
territorialisation des décisions et des
mesures et bien fonctionne dans les deux
sens et ne fonctionne pas uniquement
dans le sens de la section de liberté il
ya évidemment au niveau des libertés
la problématique de poser pour certains
secteurs notamment de l'économie les
restaurateurs le milieu de la culture
aussi c'est c'est difficile pour eux
encore aujourd'hui la coupe doit faire
justement le gouvernement s qui doit
lâcher du lest comme le demande la
plupart des représentants de ces
secteurs
à côté une fois qu'on interdit à ces
gens de travailler une fois qu'on
interdit un restaurateur d'ouvrir son
restaurant
une fois qu'on interdit à une salle de
spectacles de d'ouvrir et bien à ce
moment là il faut évidemment que le
gouvernement soit là pour compenser le
manque à gagner qui est absolument
considérable et éviter la fragilisation
de pans entiers de notre économie
avec à la clé le risque d'avoir des
centaines de milliers ou des millions de
françaises et de français sur le carreau
c'est à dire sans emploi
donc là une fois que le gouvernement
prend la décision est lourde de
conséquence de confiner ou deux fermées
administrativement
un certain nombre de lieux commerciaux
ou cultuelles et bien il faut évidemment
que le en contrepartie le gouvernement
compense réellement est intégralement le
manque à gagner qui est important alors
on peut pas laisser ces professionnels
seul face à des charges qui sont
considérables souvent des charges fixes
qui sont qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
allégée et évidemment le danger c'est
que si cette situation qui perdure déjà
depuis des mois et des mois se poursuit
encore un petit peu et bien on va avoir
par des faillites qui vont se compter
par centaines de milliers dans notre
pays et le quoi qu'il en coûte
maintenue oui je crois qu'il faut que
les mesures prises en soutien de ces
secteurs perdure évidemment le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix il doit le
faire et aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
ya beaucoup de professionnels qui en
raison de la complexité administrative
ont du mal à obtenir les aides
auxquelles israël portant droit donc il
faut absolument fluidifier ces processus
pour éviter qu'il y ait de nombreux
professionnels aujourd'hui qui non
seulement sont obligés de fermer ne
parviennent pas à obtenir les aides et
des soutiens de l'état et risque bien de
mettre la clé sous la porte dans les
prochaines semaines donc il faut que le
gouvernement non seulement met en place
des aides efficaces qui compense
réellement le manque à gagner est la
perte de chiffre d'affaires et il faut
faire en sorte que tout le monde y ait
accès y compris les petites structures
quand elles n'ont pas des juristes dans
disponibles il faut qu'elles puissent
facilement sanquer trop de complexité
administrative avoir accès à ces aides
financières alors justement au niveau
européen il ya un plan de relance qui a
été initié un plan quand même ambitieux
ce plan est ce que vous vous le soutenez
ce plan de relance il aurait été
beaucoup de défauts parce que on vous
comme toujours avec l'union européenne
s'agissant de la france ça va nous
coûter beaucoup plus cher que ce qu'on
va gagner on va toucher 39 milliards ça
va nous coûter entre 70 et 80 milliards
puisque à la clé on va contracter une
dette européenne colossal que d'être
contractés par la commission européenne
mais qui sera payée par les états
c'est-à-dire par les peuples une dette
de 750 milliards et de surcroît
là on va assister à une hausse du budget
européen dans les prochaines années
or la france fait partie des neuf pays
qui sont des contributeurs nets au
budget de l'union européenne
donc nous allons devoir payer davantage
et par conséquent c'est pas une bonne
affaire pour les français immédiatement
on va toucher et un certain nombre de
secteurs économiques en difficulté vont
effectivement touché une partie de ses
39 milliard mais derrière ça va nous
coûter beaucoup plus cher
est ce qu'on doit craindre justement les
conséquences de ce plan de relance et la
dette
finalement à qui s'inspire en fait le
problème qui est posé c'est quelle est
l'utilité d'une action de l'union
européenne dans ce domaine
on nous a toujours dit en cas de crise
l'union européenne
les jugements efficace de travail eh
bien on s'aperçoit que c'est pas le cas
et on s'aperçoit qu'on pourrait très
bien mettre en place un plan de relance
national beaucoup plus efficace et moins
coûteux qu'en passant par l'union
européenne avec de surcroît la
commission européenne qui décide de la
manière dont on va utiliser cet argent
non seulement on va payer plus ce qu'on
reçoit mais en plus on décide pas de la
manière dont cet argent sera ensuite
injecté dans l'économie française
donc on perd sur deux tableaux et puis
on le voit d'ailleurs avec la politique
vaccinale dont je parlais tout à l'heure
le fait d'organiser les choses à
l'échelle de l'union européenne dirigée
dans les bureaux gris à bruxelles
n'ajoute pas du tout et d'efficacité au
contraire ça génère des procédures
beaucoup plus longue beaucoup plus
lourde
et lorsque la france lorsque l'union
européenne a tardé avant de valider un
certain nombre de vaccins beaucoup de
pays dans le monde ont pu vacciner
massivement pendant cette période et on
le voit encore aujourd'hui avec le
vaccin
ce pique nique générés par la russie
l'union européenne à commencer par
dénigrer ce vaccin pas le mépriser
ensuite il n'a pas été validé par les
autorités européennes
le résultat c'est que ce vaccin qui
semble être tout à fait efficace
certains pays comme la hongrie se sont
affranchis des règles européennes et en
ont acheté directement et ils ont bien
fait mais les pays comme la france qui
se sont mis entre les mains de bruxelles
et bien s'en sortent le plus mal puisque
ils n'ont pas accès ils n'ont pas la
france n'a pas généré son propre vaccin
n'a pas pu a accédé en nombre suffisant
aux vaccins britannique astrazeneca est
resté dans le dans le carcan de
bruxelles et donc n'a ne disposera pas
au moins dans un laps de temps braire
ils ignoraient 2
la lycéenne aussi argumenté et affirme
qu'elle a suivi quand même les processus
de validation de ces vaccins et que ce
sont des processus très long et il
fallait être très précautionneuse
l'union européenne abe a contracté des
achats de vaccins important avec pfizer
et avec astrazeneca et avec mme diana
avec astrazeneca et bien ils n'ont pas
pris des précautions sur les lieux de
production le résultat c'est que les
pays européens globalement vont recevoir
beaucoup moins que ce qui était prévu
dans les tout prochains mois
et s'agissant du vaccin russe il
lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il a été annoncé il
ya quelques mois est bien dans les
institutions européennes
ce ça a été uniquement des sarcasmes et
du mépris et aujourd'hui ils se rendent
compte que sébastien guellal sans doute
largement aussi valables que d'autres
enquêtes validé quand même sur le vaccin
spoutnik vais en proposant une une
éventuelle collaboration est justement
même au niveau français au niveau
européen on ne rejette pas
maxence pout nick v pour l'instant ben
maintenant maintenant ils ont pris
conscience que il avait sans doute
falloir approvisionner aussi ce vaccin
spoutnik mai mais que de temps perdu
pendant très longtemps ils ont ils ont
refusé de prendre en compte ce vaccin
tels sont le vaccin spoutnik v et
tambourins de validation et il faut
lever les brevets pour permettre
justement de produire massivement les
vaccins on sait que sanofi va produire
celui de johnson & johnson et
connaissent une question qui peut se
poser en effet dès lors qu'il ya de
l'argent public qui a été injecté
massivement dans l'élaboration dans les
labos pharmaceutiques
il y aura une certaine logique ensuite à
ce que les brevets tombent assez brève
échéance dans le domaine public
voilà c'est évidemment tout dépend
évidemment des investissements qui sont
faits par ses laboratoires mais
commençons déjà par la transparence et
commençons par défendre les intérêts de
nos peuples
a fortiori lorsque c'est avec de
l'argent public que ces vaccins ont été
mis en oeuvre pour terminer un mot sur
la présidentielle le vote par
anticipation votre réaction par rapport
à ça
retailleau marine le pen dénonce une
magouille politicienne
oui je crois que c'était en effet c'est
une petite entourloupe finalement des
sans doute destinée à faire oublier la
question importante de la
proportionnelle il faut que mettre fin à
une situation française où la démocratie
représentative est très malade
pourquoi parce que l'assemblée nationale
ne plaisante pas la pluralité des
opinions de des français donc il faut
comme ma consigne était engagée par la
présidentielle instaurer la
proportionnelle comme il ne souhaite pas
le faire
eh bien il évoque cette possibilité de
vote anticipé qui pourrait donner lieu
d'ailleurs à des fraudes massives au sec
dans les pays où ça existe c'est souvent
le lieu de fraude importante donc c'est
évidemment un processus culation connais
ces trois là didier manier par
anticipation 3% la population ça
concernerait ce vote oui mais ça peut
générer des fraudes importantes
néanmoins je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne chose
le plus important si on veut que les
français se tournent vers les urnes que
l'abstention diminue eh bien il faut
restaurer une vraie démocratie
une vraie démocratie c'est deux choses
c'est à la fois des mécanismes de
démocratie directe avec notamment le
référendum d'initiative populaire tient
la possibilité pour des citoyens
un million de millions 2,3 millions de
se saisir d'un sujet est de permettre
ensuite à tous les français de voter sur
un texte de loi par exemple
et puis le gameplay ni des défilés
représentative avec la proportionnelle
pour faire en sorte que l'assemblée
représente la france s'était dit dédé
gilet jaune ça
le référendum d'initiative populaire
quasiment oui c'est exact c'était
d'ailleurs une très vieille
revendication du rassemblement national
depuis des décennies mais en effet ce
sont les gilet jaune kg exprimé avec
force avec le soutien d'une majorité de
français
donc si emmanuel macron écouter un petit
peu ce que pensent les français
eh bien il instaurerait ce référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ou d'initiative
populaire
il mettrait en oeuvre la proportionnelle
et ce qui permettrait de restaurer un
des bobos un débat démocratique de
qualité en france juste
marine le pen elle elle s'engage c'est
là ce sera peut-être l'un des enjeux
probablement à n'en pas douter de cette
présidentielle
elles disent s'engager à rembourser la
dette
finalement causé par cette crise
sanitaire
ça c'est un engagement qu'elle prend
pour la présidentielle oui bien sûr
c'est le pen fait preuve du sens des
responsabilités il n'est pas
envisageable de ne pas honorer la
signature de la france on s'agissant de
la dette publique de la france elle
était déjà très importante avant la
crise sanitaire elle avait déjà dépassé
les 2200 milliards plus de 100% du pib
aujourd'hui elle s'établit autour de
120% du pib à 2700 milliards
il faudra payer et donc si on veut payer
sans augmenter les impôts qui sont déjà
à un niveau confiscatoire en france eh
bien il faudra suscité de la croissance
et de l'emploi
c'est à dire alléger la fiscalité les
contraintes les aides qui pèsent sur nos
entreprises qui souvent paralyse
l'activité économique en france est par
ailleurs protégé notre économie avec un
certain nombre de mesures de bon sens
pour éviter les délocalisations massives
et pour éviter la concurrence déloyale
par là ce sont ces deux volets qui
permettront de relancer l'économie
française
et si on parvient à relancer l'économie
française alors nous pourrons rembourser
cette dette
parce qu'en effet c'est une obligation
morale et plus vite on la remboursera
mois elle pèsera sur les générations à
venir
et vous pensez que ce sera suffisant
justement pour casser le pacte
républicain qui empêche finalement
marine le pen d'accéder à la
magistrature suprême goûter aujourd'hui
les sondages la placent à 48% c'est à
dire que on est dans la marge d'erreur
donc ça veut dire qu'elle peut gagner à
la
sinon ciel rien n'est gagné d'avancé
bien sûr nous sommes encore à quinze
mois de l'échéance mais je crois plus
sur ces sujets là et bien nous aurons
l'occasion de montrer ces prochains mois
que nous avons un projet à la fois une
analyse lucide un projet c'est ailleurs
un projet complet et que nous pourrons
le mettre en oeuvre dès que nous
arrivons responsabilité crois qu'il une
expiration très profonde en france un
vrai changement à pédales macron qui
nous avait vendu le nouveau monde
le nouveau monde apparaît
malheureusement comme la synthèse des
défauts de l'ancien monde de l'ancien
droite et l'ancienne gauche qui ont
dominé la vie politique française
je crois qu'il y ait un peu comme
ailleurs c'est comme ça se passe
ailleurs sur la planète il leur est
venue que les patriotes arrive au
pouvoir et nous nous dans cette démarche
les biens nous entendons tendre la main
à tous ceux qui veulent en finir avec un
mode macro éviter qu'ils soient à
l'elysée pour cinq années de plus et
ainsi si nous parvenons à gagner bien
nous prend sortir la france de deux des
difficultés dans laquelle se trouvait
restaurer les français dans leurs droits
les plus essentiels
merci beaucoup à nicolas bay vous
rappelle que vous êtes le député
européen du rassemblement national merci
pour cette grande interview assez et
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à une
grande interview vous pouvez retrouver
sur nos réseaux sociaux en replay et sur
notre site internet arte france on tv
merci de votre attention à très bientôt
[Musique]